did you guys set out to be like to like
incorporate Sports into your comedy and
I mean you know because it's not well is
there some people that kind of do that I
mean it is it is I mean it's a natural
hybrid you know totally but I don't
think anyone's done it because
for and this is what we were saying I
don't think people have looked at it and
said I need this to be as funny as the
funniest comedies yeah I think in the
past people have been like let's just do
a funny sports show right and it's like
well then that's a very crucial Point
totally because then all the sports
people are like it's not Sports enough
and all the comedy people are like it's
not funny enough and you're like well
wait a minute it's Gotta fit that and so
we like putting our lens on that I'd say
if you came to see us do stand up an
hour of stand-up wouldn't have a lot of
sports in it it just doesn't because
that's that's not what we're talking
about so much but some of it does but
like I don't know we grew up in St Louis
we were huge sports fans Cardinals fans
went to the University of Michigan huge
sports fans there's always something so
funny about how serious people are are
about their yeah Sports is literally the
lowest Stakes thing in your life I mean
I was talking to my wife is just going
through breast cancer you know we've
been through that for the last year and
a half that's a real thing yeah that's
real life yeah lose if Alabama loses
like the Crimson Tide fans like lose
their brains and then they're like wait
that's the lowest stakes in your life
but it's managed to trick you into
thinking it is the highest Stakes thing
in your life that to us is hilarious
it's so funny it's so funny right like
you just took you tricked someone in the
Yankees fans who are like ready to jump
off the Verrazano Bridge right now
because they're having a bad September
and they're finally good again and like
we live through the time in New York
when they were unbeatable and so now
like those people are like we can't do
anything if this was supposed to be our
year and they're having like they're
ruining my fall and you're like wow
they're no one's ruining your phone my
younger brother when the Cubs finally
won the World Series 2016. it he had had
such a complicated love-hate
relationship of course that team since
like infancy basically that he told me I
said aren't you happy and he said like
yes I'm happy because he said I feel
like I've been in a bad marriage and now
I can get a divorce yes it's like now I
can just move on with my life closure
yeah
but in the same by the same token we
have a reverence for it an appreciation
for it so because we act like that and
for that same Cubs Victory our buddy Dan
Van Kirk who wrote on our he was he's
our co-host of dumb people town which
you've done right he's from Rochelle
Illinois big big Chicago Cubs fan and he
went to a world we helped him like get
to a World Series game and just a
wonderful wonderful guy and they win the
World Series and he's at a bar and he
sees a guy with a bottle of champagne
and two flutes two flutes and Dan's like
comes over to him cousin what's up buddy
and he is like there's a tear in his eye
and he's like I just I lost my I'm gonna
get this shot by my dad and then all we
wanted to do was see the Cubs win that's
the only thing we want to do but he died
before it could happen and damage in the
bar
wow that is a bummer
oh my god you're kidding and he's like
do I watch the end of the game or do I
this is more do we resuscitate the Cubs
are on the verge death happens all the
time this only happens every 100 years
and so nobody was like I just need
someone to toast to and Dan Dan started
to break down no tears and he's like
I'll throw it I'll I'll toast your dad
with you and he toasted this guy and
here's this moment with the stranger and
like to the and they were just so happy
because this thing and I'm like well it
it tricked you in the right way right
there you know there's like you tricked
you guys into having a real connective
moment yeah and it is connected like
people from you do go into the stands
and it's like oh wait this is the
diversity
relationships that we're all trying to
create everywhere that's the my favorite
thing about Dodgers game yes is it just
feels like one big La family Barbecue
100
multi-generational fan these of all
different kinds and you know it's the
probably the only time I feel
comfortable around people with face
tattoos yes uh like there's a teardrop
he may have killed a guy in prison
go doors no I mean I would just but that
is that is truthfully it that you turn
to someone and high five someone you've
never met before yeah give someone a I
mean like we've done it at games so that
aspect of it gives us the love that we
have for in the reverence because what
we've learned just through doing comedy
and like roast battle comedy and stuff
with Jeff Ross he's like you gotta
there's gotta be love in it if there's
no love in it if you're not because when
the best roaster when you roast or when
you're roasting people that you love yes
you're with your friends you know if we
were like snobs who were like yeah
Sports yeah those meat head losers it's
like you can only go so far in your like
understanding of what they're going
through and critique but if you're like
hey we actually love it too right we
make those weird you know mistakes is
giving it more weight than it deserves
and then it also works yeah connects
people